- [Narrator] In the Turkish
region of Cappadocia,
hidden in the hollowed rocks,
lie some of the oldest
Christian churches in the world.
The Goreme Open Air Museum is a cluster of
monasteries and churches dating all
the way back to the fourth century.
2.6 million years ago, a volcanic eruption
of the nearby Mount Erciyes resulted
in the formation of
mushroom-shaped fairy chimneys.
Each church that makes up
the Goreme Open Air Museum
is housed within a
separate soft rock cave.
More than 10 churches make up the museum.
Inside each church are wall
paintings known as Frescos,
examples of old classics from
the Byzantine Art Period.
These incredible paintings have managed to
retain their clarity and
colors throughout the years,
thanks to frequent restorations.
In 1984, the Goreme Open Air Museum
became one of the first
two sites in Turkey
to be designated a UNESCO
World Heritage Site.
But it's the museum's extensive history
and unique structures that have made it
one of Cappadocia's most
visited attractions.